Hello Everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Case: Animatronics
Now we're trying to survive until 3 am
and I actually just remembered I forgot the thing in the safe
immediately behind me. And Cat is still crawling around.
I need to...
Oh!
Wait, that's not open yet.
I need to go places. Okay.
So how will I know when 3am is?
At least my flashlight's back up and working
I just need to not use it all the time.
Shoot, where is it?
*Quietly* Fuck
Okay, so I got my flashlight.
*Scared Noise*
So, oh wait! This isn't the way to the control room
The control room is the other way. Dammit!
God dammit! I got scared away because probably wolfie.
Who's stompin' around over here
See I-I know how to survive, I've just got to be more
mindful of the sounds and be more ready to hide
And cower in fear, like little bitch
That-
Hello! Aw, shit! God Dammit!
You didn't see nothin', right?
You didn't see nothin'. Huh?
Your fool! 'Cause your dumb!
*louder* And ugly too!
Uh oh.
*Regret*
*Tense Silence*
Uh-oh.
*More Tense Silence*
Wha? Hey. What? What? No. No. No. Come on, no!
Come on! No! Come on!
*Mechanical Scream of Seven Hells*
*Sickening Crunch*
That's dumb. It's dumb and that's dumb.
That's dumb and it's dumb. I'm dumb that it's dumb
That's dumb. So dumb.
Cause somewhere in there
Oh come on! It was silent!
It wasn't moving! Oh god! Oh god! Oh god!
*Scared, worried noises*
That didn't work.
*Series of Sounds Indicating that Mark is Thoroughly Boned*
Yep. He's gonna do it.
Oh shit, he about to do it.
Ok he movin' on
That doesn't sound good.
Hopefully I- Aww! Come on!
Fuck off!
*More dastardly screams followed by the crunch*
What happened?
What happened? Did he come out of a vent?
Fuckin' behind me!
So I think I got it-
Come on!
*Clanking of feet*
No!
*In-game heavy breathing*
Okay. I thought I was dead. I thought 100% I was dead.
Because that's so strange that
as he's dropping he can spot you
I don't know. Maybe he knows where you are and he
drops and spots at the same time. I have no idea
Startin' to get hallucinated
Where is he?
Is he still in here?
No, he can't be.
Starting to get bad. I got to get out of this room.
God dammit! Are they all just going to cycle back that way towards the door?  God dammit!
I gotta get out of here. I gotta move.
No matter what I've gotta move.
Maybe if I go into this room it'll be better.
Is it better?
No. This all counts as the same room doesn't it?
Oh god, it is.
K, I gotta go
Fucking cock!
It won't leave me alone
They won't leave me alone
They won't leave me alone!
*Less heavy in-game breathing*
Thank you.
Good god! Finally! Okay, so I
gotta get to another room.
Don't just drop down.
Dammit
Man
So how do I get better? Do I get better
at all or am I supposed to- Am I supposed to somehow
know
The passcode
How would I know that?
How do I charge it?
Jesus
Okay. It's at a hundred percent so
where would it be?
Where would there be a passcode?
God damn stop.
Fucking christ
NOO!
*Very heavy in-game breathing*
Okay
Okay!
So the desk is more effective then the wardrobe. That's what we've discovered
Okay, where would there be...
Like, where in here would be a code?
I- I- that's not at all evident to me.
Where there'd be a code to turn the ventilation system back on
or maybe the key is to get, you know, the ventilation system back up.
Maybe that's what the key from surviving for so long is.
*DEATH SCREAM*
FUCK! What the fuck!?
It sounded far away!
Ugh no. It was behind me? Really? It was behind me?
Really? Is that how this works?
It was-
It was just behind me?
Hangin' out? Is that how this works-
*You know the sound by now*
Motherfu-
It was just hangin' out behind me, huh?
Oh. Hello. Hi.
*sigh*
So...
that one is still dancing around that big room
which is kind of good.
'cause that means that he's at least away...
But I s-
I hear, like, the Cat is literally only thumping around me
Where is it though? I hear it purring...
That's lovely...
Where is-
I don't even see me under the desk over there.
Bizarre...
Not good sounds.
Oh, I need to get out of this room.
Okay.
Shit. I don't know where...
*Metal creaking sound* I don't know-
Uh oh.
Shit, I don't know where...
Uh...
Wolfy went.
Oh shit!
Fuck.
Okay. God damnit!
I- I need to get out of this room.
I can't be in these rooms.
I am waaaaaay too gone...
I'm dead.
Oh, do not come in this room.
Please go AWAY!
Anywhere but here!
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
[whispers] Thank you.
Don't look back.
Don't look back. Don't look back. Don't look back. Don't look back.
[Normal voice] Okay! We're in here now.
So hopefully this is gonna cool down a little bit.
And let us... recalibrate some of our brain juice because it is all oozing out of our ears
at this point!
Okay.
Nope, vision still seems to be slightly disturbed!
God damnit! See? I have no way of knowing...
How the fuck?
Ugh. 1984.
Enter. *Error sound*
I don't know.
How would I know? There's no way of knowing. It's all just bad.
OH GODDAMNIT NO NO NO NO NOOO!
Aargh!
Do not.
Please.
Just don't.
Don't.
Leave me alone.
I earned this one.
I earned this one!
Please.
Oh come on!
The wardrobes never work!
They just never work!
They never work! They never work!
They never work! What's the point!?
God damnit!
He probably just fell from a- God fucking damnit!
Are you kidding me?
There's no metric of knowing!
THERE'S NO METRIC!
What the fuck kind of mechanic- I'm actually pissed at this.
What kind of mechanic is it.
"Wait until 3 AM!
we're not going to tell you what time it is.
we're not going to tell you what to do.
Do you need to fix the ventilation? Maybe. I don't know.
Fuck it.
Well, there's a code to do it, but I don't know."
Okay. Wa- I saw it! What is with that?
Like, appearing and then not appearing.
It's in there.  Maybe because it's crawling around the vents?
Like it doesn't render properly.
So it was in there...
Now it's gone.
Oh, what was that? Okay. So, there YOU are.
So you're all the way in the other area down there.
So I just got a cat man chasin' me down.
It's gettin' pretty dicey in here.
So, eventually I'll need to move to this area.
I just can't do it until...
wolf man has cleared it.
Which looks like he might have.
Yeah. Oh tha- yeah! That's good. Okay.
Man, he's just jittery as fuck.
Hello!
Yes, he's in here!
Man! He got there quick!
What is-
They move faster when you're lookin' at the camera for some reason.
They- They jump all over the place.
That doesn't make any sense.
Okay, but either way.
Shit.
He's coming in this room. God damnit.
Sounds near me.
Oh, there he is. Okay.
Yeah, so he's just going through the offices now.
Which is fine...
I'm assuming anyway.
I hear that!
That's lovely!
Yep, I hear you.
Thump-i-ty thump.
Teleport, thump-thump.
Where'd you go?
Wow, where did he go?
He just booked it!
Oh there he is.
So like, it is- it is- that is the case,
like, watching them makes him accelerate to his next destination.
Okay.
[Whispering] So...should be good to get outta here.
[still whispering] Pop in here first, oh no, this is a dead end.
I shouldn't be in here.
[No longer whispering] I'm gonna- Is the ventilation really gonna just-
let me go?
Okay...
You said that already!
Does- OH AUTOSAVE! GOOD!
DID I GET SOMETHING?!
Hi. Hi friend, how ya doin'?
Thank goodness it autosaved, because honestly fuck you.
And fffffuck you.
In case it wasn't clear enough the first time.
So did I get it? Am I halfway there?
Am I having fun yet?!
Alright.
Guess I'll just pop outta here and charge it and get under the table.
*silent ninja drop*
Shit.
OH FU- OH GOD DAMNIT!
HE FUCKING TELEPORTED WHEN I WAS LOOKING AT THE-
*ugh*
*Resounding clang*
Wha- what is that?!
What is that?!
Wha- I have the keycard now?!
WHAT?!
Excuse me?
What?
What- Hello!
Hi!
Who are you?
What am I- *phone rings* Oh okay...
Yeah... Okay...Yeah, Okay, Alright. Okay, alright.
[Phone guy] It seems you have met another one of my creations?
[Mark] Yeah, the guy on the other side.
[Phone guy] Your luck surprises me.
[Mark] I- I don't know
[Phone guy] Okay. That's it. No more playing around.
So this was all just fun and games before?
[Phone guy] Toys went on a hunt! Turn around... Surprise!
Hi!
Who are you?
"Do not walk away from the owl while she sees you."
Oh, okay.
Well that's good!
So what do I do?
Pleh.
"Use the battery pack to turn on the radio."
I don't know if I have...
a battery pack.
So, am I just supposed to stay here?
Forever?
What am I-
What am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do?!
HI! WANNA BE FRIENDS?
It literally said do not walk away from the owl when it sees you.
What happens if I move?
Oh.
Oh, okay!
So the radio was over here, right?
Do I somehow have a battery pack now?
No I do not.
*Mechanical scream, once more*
Fuck! Wow, okay... jeezums!
Hi!
Oh. Hello.
Sorry. Didn't mean to interrupt.
You- You have a good one.
"Use the battery pack to turn on the radio."
I don't have a battery pack.
I ain't got one!
What are you talking about?
I think it like, jumped- *loud noise*
What?
I think it like, jumped me forward a bit.
In the game, maybe it took pitty on me.
Finally.
So what am I supposed to do about that owl?
I it just gonna sneak up randomly?
And where the hell do I get a battery pack?
I don't know half the things you're telling me about.
Maybe I gotta get the battery pack from behind the owl?
Uh oh! Woah! Hey! Hi! How are you doing?
Didn't mean to do that.
Okay. Goodbye!
*You know the drill*
Okay! Alright, you know what? I'm done.
I can't do this episode anymore.
I made progress which is pretty good,
so in the next episode, I'm gonna try and find a way to get through this.
Even though it's non-descript
and the lack of direction IS KILLING ME!
but, I'm getting through it.
So thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always:
I will see you in the next video!
Bye-bye!